[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Daniela Blandón Daniela saludo
nuevamente para usted Hola Ángela vamos
a hacer la actualización Vamos a
continuar hablando de Europa y esta
búsqueda por nuevas normas para el
mercado eléctrico Pues están reunidos
los ministros de energía de la Unión
Europea este lunes en Luxemburgo están
discutiendo estas nuevas reglas con dos
objetivos primero expandir la energía
baja en emisiones de carbono y segundo
evitar que se repita la crisis
energética del año pasado cuando los
precios récords del gas dejaron a los
consumidores con una energía
vertiginosamente cara y amenazados con
un apagón en cualquier momento algo que
finalmente no ocurrió pero Estuvieron
muy cerca la reforma propuesta Busca que
los precios de la energía sean más
estables y más predecibles ahora una vez
que los países acuerden su postura deben
negociar esta actualización final con el
legislativo comunitario y aprobar la ley
antes de las elecciones parlamentarias
que van a el próximo año Bueno pero para
que esto se logre Daniela primero van a
tener que atravesar una serie de
obstáculos de qué se trata Pues hay
diferencias entre todos los países las
conversaciones se han complicado por una
propuesta de Suecia que ocupa la
presidencia rotatoria de la Unión
Europea para permitir que los países
prolonguen los subsidios para las
centrales eléctricas de Carbón lo que se
hace hoy en día es que se les paga no
por lo que produzcan precisamente sino
porque tengan disponibilidad cuando se
les necesite independientemente de que
no estén produciendo Polonia lo acepta
Alemania Bélgica y Luxemburgo se oponen
y también están las voces neutras como
Francia que pidió una solución que
mantenga la ambición climática Sí pero
que también refleje las circunstancias
individuales de cada país
y las dificultades de descarbonizar no
que siguen en el centro siempre así es
bien Daniela grandes multinacionales
ofrecen empleos para refugiados se ve
como una muy buena noticia más esperemos
que cumplan esta promesa porque como
antesala del Día Mundial del refugiado
que se celebra Este martes empresas
multinacionales como Amazon también los
hoteles Marriott y Hilton se
comprometieron a contratar por lo menos
a unas 13.000 refugiados en Europa
incluidas mujeres ucranianas que han
huido de la guerra con Rusia eso Durante
los próximos tres años en total
participará en unas 40 compañías que
también ofrecieron facilitar conexiones
o capacitar a más de 200.000 de estas
personas y es que según Naciones Unidas
110 millones de personas han sido
desplazadas en todo el mundo con un
estimado de 12 millones de Ucrania desde
donde se ha dado el mayor movimiento de
refugiados del continente desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial Pues aquí Habría
que ver cómo es la discriminación para
entregar esas ayudas porque me llama la
atención Daniela que menciona las
mujeres ucranianas que son
importantísimas pero no más que las
mujeres de otros países que buscan
refugio
bien Daniela y no podemos dejar por
fuera de la agenda por supuesto el tema
de Anthony blinken en China después de
haberse reunido con
Cuáles son los temas de importancia
económica de que estos dos países limen
sus asperezas pues Ángela los vínculos
entre las dos economías más grandes del
mundo llevan años dañados por conflictos
comerciales territoriales y políticos y
sus canales de comunicación son casi
nulos Pues esta relación de amor y odio
es seguida en todo el mundo ya que pues
un mayor deterioro de los lazos Podría
tener implicaciones globales no
solamente en los mercados financieros
también en las rutas comerciales y en
las cadenas de suministros analistas
advierten de la importancia de mantener
este vínculo
creo que la relación entre Estados
Unidos y China ciertamente se encuentra
en una etapa muy crítica desde que china
abrió su economía del resto del mundo a
finales de la década de 1970 Estados
Unidos y China se convirtieron en
importantes socios comerciales de hecho
China el mayor socio comercial de
Estados Unidos y ha proporcionado
algunos productos esenciales a los
consumidores estadounidenses durante las
últimas dos décadas Cuáles son las
fricciones comerciales más recientes
Ángela Washington ha apuntado a empresas
de chinas en todo el sector tecnológico
con medidas que incluyen controles de
exportación de semiconductores e
Inteligencia artificial hasta una
posible prohibición de la aplicación de
videos cortos tiktok al que la casa
blanca acusa de ser un riesgo para la
seguridad la rencilla más reciente tiene
que ver con los chips pues como
represalia de lo anterior Beijing
prohibió a los principales fabricantes
de infraestructura comprar productos del
estadounidense Michael citando temores
sobre su seguridad nacional
vamos ahora a los indicadores Ángela
Pues precisamente en esta reunión están
puesto los ojos del mercado Por lo que
hablábamos anteriormente las dos
principales economías del mundo Asia
operó a la baja con Tokio perdiendo el
1% y con excepción de la bolsa
australiana que sí está subiendo o subió
mejor en la jornada en Europa tienen el
mismo comportamiento analistas lo
atribuyen a que después de esta reunión
entre el principal diplomático
estadounidense y el presidente chino
pues no hubo señales concretas de
Progreso en el mejoramiento de las
relaciones diplomáticas Wall Street es
cerrado por festivo bueno no hubo mucho
tiempo para conversar Daniela pero lo
compensamos mañana con más noticias acá
nos vemos mañana pues muchas gracias